[Applause]
my message to the numbers for so long
there are many factors in this country
that has led us to perceive each other
in different lengths some of us who are
ignorant among the Muslims you
african-americans as folks engaged and
those of us who are ignorant among the
non-muslim see Muslims as terrorists and
just wanted to take over the country for
no reason
what were those things are untrue so we
want you to know that the Muslim
community is here for the Muslim
community
[Music]
put on the holy book of the Muslims
God is not asking us God is not pleading
us God is commanding us just to be our
ally no matter what happens and any
Muslim that decent that disagrees with
this you not know anything about your
own faith
[Applause]
yeah you mean I mean abilities say
Shahada
any lung you wanna wanna
coochie-coo what a while
Lucy Combes I win while a tiny one Bobby
yakulani and alpha P follow a Latina the
Latin deputy no way out or remove inna
llaha can I be mad meruna for me more
you